Taylor Swift has turned her eras tour
it's this big tour where she went all
around the country and it was sold out
everywhere and I had The Misfortune of
Being in downtown Nashville on a night
when the concert let out and I felt like
I was in a third world country you
couldn't get a car there were a
gazillion people flooding into the
street it was Mayhem people go crazy
when Taylor Swift announced her concert
tour every woman in this office I walk
in you I show up here early I'm here
earlier than almost anybody and the
moment I come in this is the very very
beginning of the work day just as I come
in from my show all the girls are
refreshing the page to try to get the
early tickets from American people love
Taylor Swift I have never in my life
consciously intentionally listened to a
Taylor Swift song I couldn't I couldn't
name a Taylor Swift song the one the one
exception to that is the the one about
I'm a problem it's you or I'm a problem
it's me guess that would make more sense
uh because my producers made me listen
listen to it to react to it on the show
but I I couldn't tell you what a Taylor
Swift song is other than that well she
turned this bestselling tour into a
movie and the movie has held the number
one spot at the box office for the
second weekend it surged well over a
$100 million it's made history is the
first concert film ever to cross the
$100 million
Mark why why I don't am I going to have
to go see this movie am I going to have
I have avoided the Taylor Swift eras
tour I might have to go see
it to make sense of this cultural
phenomenon because I have an
inkling of why Taylor Swift does so well
I don't mean to diminish Taylor
Swift she has a lot of things to
recommend her is she Bach is she Mozart
no I don't think so is
she the greatest Lyricist or musician or
singer or dancer ever no is she the most
glamorous Hollywood star ever no is she
no and actually I think that's why she's
so
popular she's just kind of
normal and in in another
age that would be fine and she might be
popular but in our age which is so
abnormal which exalts
abnormality and bizarre things people
crave something that's normal she's just
kind of Nic
looking
blonde doesn't have any tattoos doesn't
have any piercings doesn't when she Mak
statements about politics they're
relatively mild center-left
perfectly socially acceptable statement
acceptable to the ruling class still
basically acceptable to the
populace she sings songs about her
ex-boyfriends that's Bas that's pretty
much it everyone kind it's a relatable
experience there's nothing particularly
profound in any of the songs I'm not
sure there's very much meaningful at all
in the songs but she's just kind of
normal and being kind of normal is
enough in an age that has gone
completely insane it's no secret that
here at the daily wire we all love
speaking of our faces genus L Dark Spot
Corrector you might be asking what does
this product even do well we've all got
sunspots brown spots discoloration or
dry skin with the genus Cell Dark Spot
Corrector you can watch these blemishes
disappear in front of your very eyes
Kimberly from Youngstown Ohio says my
appearance has improved so much since
using genu cell on my face I love all my
genus cell products and my skin looks
younger now it's your turn to feel like
Kimberly but this sale is ending very
soon take advantage of Jus cell's most
popular package which includes the Dark
Spot Corrector plus the classic genus
cell bags and pinous treatment and
immediate effects all for almost 70% off
genus cell is so confident in their
products that you can try them for
yourself completely risk-free if you
don't see results in one day you will
get your money back it's very simple go
to genucell.com
nlls YT letter y letter T start looking
years even decades younger tomorrow say
hello to the best skin you've ever had
at Jus cell.com
nsyt letter y letter T jus.com
nsyt speaking of what people want very s
study came out showing that nearly one
in four adults across the world report
feeling very or fairly lonely this is
according to a metag Gallup survey this
is not just a survey of Americans or a
certain age bracket new survey was taken
across 142 countries found that 24% of
people age 15 and older self-reported
feeling very or fairly lonely in
response to the question how lonely do
you feel the survey also found that the
rates of loneliness were highest in
young people so you might expect older
people maybe whose friends have died who
have suffered all sorts of losses lived
a little bit that they might be lonelier
no it's younger people the young people
who were supposed to be out and
constantly around other young people and
going on dates and just surrounded by
social life they report being the
loneliest 27% of young adults aged 19 to
29 report feeling very or fairly lonely
and the the lowest rates were actually
found in older adults only 177% of
people aged 65 and older reported
feeling lonely why is this why is
everybody so lonely part of it is that
we are living in that uh how does it
affect you culture what we were talking
about at the very top of the show the
culture which says ignore social
questions ignore any uh need for
consensus any agreement on anything in
society how does it affect you let
people do whatever decadent Divergent
depraved things they want to do just you
do you and I'll do me and we'll we'll
just do different things well a
consequence of that is we're going to be
more isolated we're not going to have as
much in common and we're not going to
have as much to say to one another and
we're not going to we're going to feel
alienated that's part of it but at a
deeper level why are people people
lonely at a deeper level the loneliness
pandemic is directly attributable to the
decline and sidelining of virtue it
comes down to that because true
friendship is only possible among
virtuous people Good Old Uncle Aristotle
told us this Millennia ago there there
are three kinds of friendship we could
say friendship of pleasure you know we
both like meatballs and
martinis friendship of
utility which is we we can help each
other professionally
say and friendships of
virtue where people who are basically
good who practice virtue and TT down
Vice spend time with one another because
they're
both oriented toward the good and
working toward the good and when you are
oriented toward and looking working
toward the good you get happier and when
you're oriented toward and doing things
that are bad you get less
happy
there's a good book by Alistair McIntyre
a a still living philosopher called
after virtue a highly recommended book
because it it talks about this very
problem we have sidelined virtue we have
forgotten about virtue many people in
our culture mock the notion of virtue
and they say it's
illusory and that's bad and if you if
you don't care about virtue at all you
might end up in Hell someday you're
going to have probably a miserable life
you're going to fall into bad habits
you're going to do all sorts of things
but one of the least discussed aspects
of that is you're going to have a harder
time making friends I'm not saying that
if you are lonely right now it's because
you are not virtuous it's a social
problem if you live in in a just if
living in a culture that denies and
Sidelines virtue is going to greatly
increase the chances that you're going
to be lonely and have troubl making
friends because it's a social problem
it's not just about what you do it's
about what everybody does but then there
it is there is the answer to that
question how does it affect you how does
it affect you if we pass some law well
because the law is a teacher and it it
molds the populace just as education
molds children well how does it affect
you it affects me because I live in a
society and when you pass laws and when
you have rituals and culture that is
going to warp the the the fabric in
which I move the fabric of the space in
which I move and that is going to create
a certain kind of society and that
affects me a lot boy what a great clip
that was now hey hey hey hey man you got
to ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael n's YouTube channel we'll see
you next time